Subhan Allah. It certainly has a lot
more involved in it than I was
expecting. Thank you. Dr. Zakir,
are there any other
compulsory
fasts other than the month of Ramadan
that a Muslim must observe?
>> The fasts can be broadly categorized
into further fasts that are obligatory
and the other is the tataw fast. that is
the voluntary fast or the non-obligatory
fast which inshallah we'll be dealing
maybe on the episode 31. As far as
obligatory fasts are concerned you can
classify it under four types. The first
as we are discussing the obligatory fast
during the month of Ramadan. The second
is if a person misses the fast of
Ramadan for any reason
cover up the fast miss. It's known as
kadafas.
The third is fasting for expiration
of the sins. If you committed a sin and
you have to fast, give a kafara. That's
the third type. And the fourth is
fasting if you're vowed to fast. So
these are basically the four types of
fur fasting which are there in Islam.
Yes.